c'est au nom car ous les marrons 8 sur
trois premières les fêtes c'est aussi
bien sûr l'époque des truffes tout le
monde aime les truffes mais il ya truffé
truffe comment reconnaître un chien
comestibles d'affirmer niveau là le
problème
la truffe de ce chien n'est pas
comestible c'est un chien qui a une
folle si vous rencontrez un chien avec
une wolf comme ça projeté le c'est un
fier wendel et chats domestiques ne
présente pas de vol chaque massif
soliste pas comment le shaq massive ce
qui se branche sur les chiens mangent
pas halal viande plus compte pour nous
c'est pas bien on peut pas parler de ça
non alimentaire il va voir du sujet donc
vous me dire ça mais c'était pour parler
des truffes tu vois moi je voulais faire
un sujet sur les primes voici cartouches
c'est un espagnol berrichon l'epagnol
berrichon est un animal charmant
malheureusement il est très peureux
voyez vous comme il frémit
c'est un animal qui a tendance à frémir
il et frémissant et bien dès qu'il
commence à frémir
vous prenez un petit peu vous couvrez
d'abord elle vous prenez un peu de
farine blueant la farine voulu en avec
la farine plus rend pas de cuisine
gluante bas c'est un peu de frais
pas faire ça on peut pas faire d'autres
choses c'est pourtant déçu parce que je
déconne qui si adroitement palmer
avalanche à la hauteur où s'écrivit sur
2 3e voici cartouches
c'est un boxeur à poil vous comme vous
le voyez c'est un boxeur le boxeur poids
lourds semblent tous les autres boxeurs
sauf qu'il a les poils durs la grande
qualité du boxeur à poil mou c'est que
c'est un animal très attachant pour
éviter qu'il n'attache utiliser la toile
force plomb dans la poêle
enfin tous les bons coups de bras ça
c'est pas possible on trouve quoi c'est
gênant que fait trois fois qu'on
recommence sur commence avec la gauche
comme celle que j'aurais trouvé sympa de
38 ans nelly docteur house les noirs
vivent sur quatre premières et bien
voici cartouches cartouche est un bassin
géant
le passager ans comme vous le savez
c'est un passé qui a toutes les
caractéristiques du passé ordinaire sauf
qui est un peu plus court surface c'est
un animal charmant malheureusement il a
un grand défaut c'est que c'est un
animal qui est assez fuyant c'est à dire
qu'il est il a tendance à ceux à se
sauver alors s'il se sort s'il se sauver
faites le revenir dans quoi dans l'huile
vidange d'huile vides en jaune - cette
demoiselle but mais la saison mais
envoyer même pas l'étiquette rien faire
[Musique]
fait étonnant non